Speaker 1: Welcome everybody. Hope you had a
good weekend, a lot of different things going on,
and I want to jump right into it. You know, one of
the things that was good last week that happened
on the one year anniversary of the January six
Trump riots was that at least in some circles,
there was a message which we heard multiple
times, which is OK. It's been a year
and a year ago, it didn't work. The insurrection
failed. The attempt at a coup failed to actually
keep the guy who didn't win in power. But instead
of saying great, it failed. We don't need to
think about it anymore. Many prominent voices
have been saying the coup attempt continues.
They're going to go crazy in 2024, trying to do it
again. And they may even try it to some degree in
2022. And unless we're prepared, it has been made
clear that were they slightly less incompetent,
they might have pulled it off. Still unlikely,
they truly would have pulled it off. But the major
and basic systems of democracy that we in some
sense take for granted could have failed us. And
there are a bunch of different pieces that I want
to mention to you today that have been published,
which I think are really, really good and step
back for a second and think about from how many
different areas we are hearing this. Former
military generals, former U.S. presidents,
some of the most quoted thinkers of our time, like
Noam Chomsky and on and on and on. So let's just
jump right in and take a look now. Last week,
we already looked at this first example.
Retired general warns the U.S. military could back
a coup after the 2024 election. I have an entire
clip on this on the YouTube channel, so I won't
redo it. But the gist of this was that actually
three retired generals are warning that if
in 2024 we saw another desire and another
attempt for Republicans to take an election
that they did not win if they had the support
of the upper echelon of the military. If the
upper echelon of the military believed that the
person that won didn't actually win and decided
to help the insurrectionists, the outcome could
be completely different. In other words, that the
coup could succeed if the insurrectionists had the
upper echelon of the military on their side.
We talked about that last week. Also last week
we started. We are starting to see concern in
Canada are friendly neighbors to the north of. If
the U.S. is no longer democratic, what does that
mean for us? How do we need to protect ourselves?
And I told you about this report and article from
the Canadian political science professor Thomas
Homer Dixon, who is saying, we in Canada, this is
not even a warning to Americans. This is Thomas
Homer Dixon warning his own country and saying we
could have a right wing dictatorship in the United
States by 2030, depending on what happens in 22
and in 24 and theoretically, subsequently in 2028.
With the continued erosion of a continued
growth of this authoritarian right wing movement
bolstered to some degree, by the way, by some left
wingers looking away and saying there's nothing to
see here that that's also part of the problem,
but mostly the people doing it are the problem.
The U.S. could be a right wing dictatorship
by 2030, but there are more concerns,
and I think it's great that this is
being published from different voices
because it is so important to understand. Jimmy
Carter wrote a really good piece last week on the
eve of the Jan. six Trump riot anniversary in the
New York Times called I Fear for our democracy.
And this is part of a number of essays that
were published, and it's very, very much worth
reading. But in it, Jimmy Carter says one year on
promoters of the lie that the election was stolen
have taken over one political party and
stoked distrust in our electoral systems.
These forces exert power and influence
through relentless disinformation, which
continues to turn Americans against Americans.
According to the Survey Center on American Life,
36 percent of Americans agree that the traditional
American way of life is disappearing so fast
that we may have to use force to save it. The
Washington Post recently reported roughly 40
percent of Republicans believe violent action
against the government is sometimes justified.
And in this in this, Jimmy Carter says they seek
to win by any means. And many Americans are being
persuaded to think and act, likewise threatening
to collapse the foundations of our security and
democracy with breathtaking speed. I now fear that
what we have fought so hard to achieve globally.
The right to free fair elections unhindered by
strongmen politicians who seek nothing more than
to grow their own power has become dangerously
fragile at home. Good for Jimmy Carter. Noam
Chomsky Noam Chomsky says the Republicans
soft coup is still underway one year after
the Capitol assault, and this includes transcripts
of an interview with With Chomsky, where he says
participants in the assault on the Capitol
doubtless had varying perceptions and motives,
but were united in the effort to overthrow an
elected government, in short, an attempted coup,
by definition. It was, furthermore, an attempt
that could have succeeded if a few prominent
Republican figures had changed their stance and
gone along with the coup attempt. And if the
military command had made different decisions.
Chomsky referencing what the retired generals
say If you get the military, the outcome can
be different. Trump was making every effort to
facilitate the coup, which would surely have been
applauded by a large majority of Republican voters
and by the Republican political leadership, with
which, with few exceptions, groveling at his feet
in a shameful display of cowardice
implications for the future are all too
clear. The Republican organization is carefully
laying the groundwork for success next time.
Whatever the electoral outcome might be.
This is very, very serious, and lastly,
Jim, Chris Singer with a good piece opinion,
what authoritarianism would look like in America,
where he writes. Many Americans don't fear a
potential slide into authoritarianism because
they have no basis for doing so. Our oceans and
hegemony have coddled us. We take democracy for
granted. But democracy and the rule of law
are not the normal state of governments,
certainly not historically pointing out
authoritarianism wouldn't happen overnight.
But authoritarian regimes have shown us a road
map if Trump and his enablers get their way,
how you experience your life would depend on
whether you identified and were identified as a
Trump Republican, identified as a Trump Republican
with your bumper sticker. You'd be more likely
to get a warning instead of a speeding ticket.
You'd gain the inside track for government jobs,
grants and permits. Decisions about government
benefits like unemployment and disability would
be more likely to go your way. Your children
would be more likely to win scholarships and
admission to their chosen schools. You'd get
more favorable loan and mortgage treatment,
better access to scarce goods. The best tickets
regulations would be interpreted in your favor,
maybe just ignored. You could rely on the criminal
justice and judicial systems to go easy on you.
If not, help you out. This is a very, very much
worth reading article, and there are a lot of
people already saying the 2024 election is going
to be bonkers nuts. You are going to see them put
up claims of fraud just like they did in 2020,
but they may have secretaries of state election
administrators actually willing to do the flip.
Remember, in Georgia, Brad Raffensperger said,
We're not going to do that. We're not going to do
that. They may actually lay the groundwork where
they do have secretaries of state willing to play
ball. And I don't think we're going to have to
wait until 2024 to see it. I believe the midterms
are going to show us where we are headed and how
quickly. And so there's a lot of people in the
right wing media who dismiss Jan. six because
it failed. And you would better believe that if
they had succeeded and Trump was still president,
some of those very people saying it wasn't really
anything because it failed would be praising it as
a victory for the real winner. So those people you
can't listen to, they don't care about democracy,
they're against it. If democracy leads to an
outcome they don't want. It's not been a priority
of the Republican Party for a really long time.
And unfortunately, there is now a whole series
of clones of Donald Trump that are out there
in Congress and running for office in 2022
and no doubt in 2024. So good for all of these
people continuing to point out this is not over.
It's not. They tried it once and it failed. And
now we move on. They're going to try it again.